we flew into Pyongyang in North Korea
with little idea what to expect when we
landed
but we arrived on an invitation from the
government and that normally comes when
the country's ready to celebrate
something of national significance we
touched down at the brand-new
International Airport only ago it is
virtually empty very few flights coming
in and out of here each day but it is
impressive and it's the first thing you
see when you arrive in North Korea on
Saturday the country will celebrate the
70th anniversary of the founding of the
Workers Party we expect there to be a
major military parade there will also be
choreographed demonstrations dance
routines and musical performances in
Pyongyang they're practicing them in
open spaces ready for this major
occasion were accompanied all the time
by two government guides Mr Kim and Miss
Lee today they took us on the official
tour of Pyongyang the North Korea that
the government wants us to see this the
latest stop on the tour after lunch
which is Pyongyang middle school number
one which means it is supposedly the
best school in Pyongyang where else
would they take us
were taken up to a classroom for a
special musical performance laid on just
for us
I was allowed to speak to some of the
students about the 70th anniversary this
weekend we will do our best to live up
to the warm solicitude of sovereign
leader kim jeong-hoon
these two boys tell me this girl tells
me she enjoys her study her performance
and her dance we DPRK students have
nothing to envy in the world from the
center of Pyongyang we drove to the
outskirts and the next stop on our
official tour of the country so this is
the latest stop I think the last stop on
the tour for today which is an elderly
people's home which was chosen
specifically in this site is this right
by Kim Jong chose this site and we're
going to follow the tour now that he
took when he came here last month
last month it was be quiet
we were taken up to the cinema to watch
a film with some of the residents then
down to the surgery fully kitted out
doctor and all so we've been to the best
school and the best and in the gym I was
serenaded by an old lady wearing the
regulation tracksuit whilst walking on a
treadmill of course some of the
residents here are old enough to
remember all three leaders of the Kim
dynasty kim ill sung kim jong ill and
the current leader Yong Kim Jong ho
there have been some hard times and
difficult times but we successfully
overcame them
now the illustrious supreme leader Kim
Jong Il is leading us we have nothing to
envy in the world there's that phrase
again nothing to envy the second person
to set to us today I suspect it will be
the theme of the celebrations on
Saturday North Korea showing everybody
else that all is good at least we think
that's what's going to happen because of
course we haven't been told yet Alistar
Bangla Sky News Pyongyang in North Korea